let's go next to our caller from the 75
for area code who's calling today from
seven five four and where are you
calling from as well hi my name is John
and ooh and I'm comfortable couch
Florida hey how you doing John I'm doing
good and yeah my question for you is I'm
going to actually about generational
theory and especially about the Sprouse
how theory on generation and I have yeah
I actually interviewed was it's I think
it was how I interviewed how about it
and if I recall correctly or was it
Strauss now I don't remember if I recall
correctly isn't Steve Anand like a big
follower of that yeah yeah yeah I mean
listen
I don't have an undiluted answer I
wasn't kind of he kind of looting and
corruption in his own you know way yes
kind of you know Charlie or for some
sort of right-wing populism right so
like no way the straw house theory like
do you actually look at it like some
people say there's some mister giving a
virus because they say it takes in the
post and rake no idea of generation but
I feel like that's that's it might seem
unscientific like as it is now but it's
like is that you look into this theory
they reaching line up with a lot of
stuff that which stands for last
82 you know 160 years here's the thing
John so here's the thing in general
anytime that you'd say so you're
completely right that Strauss how
generational theory is a theory that is
not a be testable because all we can do
is see whether it applies whether we can
apply it historically it's almost like
what's called in in a graphical science
it's a best fit line it's we're taking
all of this data and we're after the
fact drawing a line that looks like a
pattern and so this is just like a
systemic limitation of this type of
theory that's qualitative rather than
quantitative and we're applying it
retroactively Lee so for me whenever I
see a theory like that it could be an
interesting theory or not an interesting
theory there can be elements of it that
we should sort of consider in terms of
they would tell us about how the future
is going to go or should be handled but
beyond that you you need to make sure
you're not trying to apply these
theories that are used retro actively to
find patterns after the fact
you don't want to over apply them to
figuring out the future when it's not
actually warranted by the type of theory
that it is yes the is that saying um the
best way to predict the future is to
look into the past sure I feel like this
was very really you know goes
internet-like is the you know the tooth
the tooth fairies
no no Neil Howe and William Strauss they
looked into you no no no five hundred
years of American envel history yes and
were able to climb certain patterns like
okay whoa like every 80 years there's a
crisis that happens by discern you know
you know discerning like no each
generation like you know they're waking
in the hide and weakening unraveling in
crisis when crisis comes it goes
especially highs like oh wait like it's
like you know just the way the pattern
you know goes like design exactly saying
that okay the future but it's like how
each generation and archetype know the
hero the the no-man's and the Civic in
the artist might each of them has an
archetypical to that tonight some
something somewhat predictably we
actually that's predictable but you know
each iteration each you know event is
different absolutely let me ask you this
question John knowing that what specific
actions could we or should we be taking
now for improving the future
okay so right now when you look into the
theory it's the same right now we're
missing in the crisis mode of the
generations apparently when the point of
time where no you know great
international conflict you cannot make
downturn no social cohesion is in isn't
a death is in incur aging like this like
down right it was like currently the
crisis is like this every 22 years with
each generation of most so currently
you're in the final half of the of the
crisis move and we had really had the
economic meltdown and go aid so but
what's it
what should we do on the basis of having
identified that pattern so what we
should do is like yeah apparently it's
like we can't complete the painting but
we can see it and how it goes
and currently web saying is we're
looking right now international
confident God okay yeah so I understand
I understand you're saying that that's
what we're looking at but again what I
would start to think about when we want
to really understand what which of these
models are useful what we want to know
is how can we apply it to the current
situation to actually do something to
improve and I'm not saying that we can't
I'm just saying it seems that you
haven't yet identified a that no no I'm
not saying like you know I'm trying to
get oh how can the world is looking like
oh whoa
like what happening between World War
two and the Great Depression
it feels so eerie similarly no - what's
going on currently in art now day and
age I feel like okay currently damn we
can live again to a third world war
which I'm not react
I'm are we advocating for but it seems
so likely like taking into third world
war was going on internationally we have
the next Great Depression
I just over stretched a recession
currently how is going on and not be
kendama can no financial system gotcha
okay so it's pattern recognition you're
using it to recognize pennies all right
John thank you appreciate it yes I'm
familiar with it and check out the
interview on my channel ok related to
that because that is it is a doozy